[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
اليوم الذي اقر فيها الملك المؤسس الملك
عبد العزيز طيب الله تراه العلم بشكله
الحالي هو يوم العلم وذلك في 27 ذي الحجه
1355 الموافقه 11 مارس
1937 وهو نفس البيرق والرائح التي حملها
جند الدوله السعوديه الاولى والثانيه قبل
300 سنه والعلم رمز الحاكم والمحكوم
والدوله وللرمز دلاله واحده ومعنى محدد
يتفق الجميع على معرفتها هو علمنا رمز
الشهاده والتوحيد هو علمنا رمز الرخاء
والنماء والتطور هو علمنا نعشقه طوال
العام ونحتفل فيه في يوم 11 مارس رفرف يا
رايه العز من فوق الغمام وابشر ابشر يا
وطنا ليحان الوعد كلنا من دون حدك على خط
الامان ليش زعل من نا ايام بالراجل ورعد
[تصفيق]
ونحتفل باليوم الوطني قبل تساوي الليل مع
النهار باربعه ايام الاعتدال الخريفي في
ثلاث وعشرين سبتمبر ونحتفل بيوم العالم
قبل تساوي الليل مع النهار باربعه ايام
الاعتدال الربيعي فيه 11 مارس وكلاهما
تكون الاجواء في غايه الاعتدال واللطف هذه
بلادي وانا طول يطاولها في ساحه المجد او
نجم يدانيها ومهره العرب الاحرار لو عطشت
نصب من دمنا ماء
ونرويها
[موسيقى]